(classical music)
- OMG.
I love this band.
- I've been listening to
'em for like, 17 years.
Got all their albums
in cassette and vinyl.
- Well I got my vinyl
signed at a pop up shop
in Chinatown.
- I caught 'em at the
mammal exhibit a while back.
- The mammal exhibit?
What is it, like a new venue?
- No, no, at the Natural History Museum.
Super chill.
- Oh, chill.
- Chill.
Wanna grab a PBR?
(crowd cheering)
- I could just die right now.
She is my goddess.
- Tell me about it.
I follow her on Instragram,
Snapchat, Facebook
and Linkedin.
- I don't even care that
it cost $400 for a ticket.
- I totally quit my job
just so I could have
enough time to buy these tickets online
before they sold out.
- [Group] We love you
person with only one name.
- Man, this is my jam.
- For sure.
Ratmaster Jeffrey's the go.
- But he isn't better than Jay-z.
- Oh for sure, but
maybe better than Kanye.
- Hold up.
Better than Kanye?
- Yeah, I'd pick him over Kanye,
maybe even over Kendrick.
- Kendrick?
(classical music)
- I love how the mandolin
and the windchimes
just speak to my soul.
- Your soul is beautiful.
- Shh.
We should stop talking.
We don't want our voices
to overpower the music.
- You're right, let's just sway.
- Oh my gosh, I love this song.
- Tell me about it.
She Looked Good in Her Camo
Wedding Dress is a classic.
- You got that right.
But it's not as good as that other song.
- Which one is that?
- You know the one about the
girl and the pickup truck?
- I Love Her More Than My Pickup Truck?
- No, no the other one.
- I Knew She Was Alone When She Pulled Up
in a Red Ram 2500?
- That's the one.
- You know who else is good?
- Who?
- That Miley girl.
- How great is this mosh pit?
- Yeah, I don't know, I've been in better.
- Really?
I feel I've gotten a couple good bruises.
- Oh that's pretty good but is a mosh pit
really a mosh pit if you
don't get your nose broken?
- Do you remember the pit
back at the Dirty Cellar?
- Awesome mosh pit.
I got hit in the head with
like four beer bottles.
- I got punched in the
face, kicked in the groin,
and I got stabbed.
Mosh pit.
- Mosh pit.
(wild music)
(classical music)
(clapping)
(country music)